hello welcome back to trigonometry as
you know we put out an interview here
every single Sunday once a week but what
we thought we'd do is we've got a few
extra episodes in the bank where we talk
to somebody about something that's not
really a core subject a core issue that
we normally talk about so we've got a
few slightly shorter slightly different
episodes that we'll be putting out and
this is one of them so sit back relax
and enjoy what do I get
do I not get to speak thankfully not
what well Anton unlike me I'm done
I quit right that's it I'm off see you
later the podcast is gonna be a lot
better now hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster i'm
konstantine kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet of subjects they
know nothing about trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts are brilliant guests this week
as a former drug dealer and the author
of dope world which is this book here
which we'll be talking about
nikka vorobyev welcome to trigonometry
all right thanks very much for having me
what's up everyone home sup mom sorry I
wore this shirt that is the first shout
out to your parents we've had on the
show
welcome listen before we get into the
interview just tell everybody you've had
quite a journey through life so tell us
a little bit about what what it's been
like yeah so originally I was born in in
Leningrad and was then the Soviet Union
came to Britain about the mid nineties
and lived in bath which is a great sort
of city for visiting if you are like a
French theater on the exchange trip but
when you actually live there it's kind
of yeah so yeah it's enough to turn a
man to crime which I did I wasn't very
good at it I got caught and because I
still have no work I think I became an
author so here we are
well you summarized it quite neatly but
actually I think having read the book
your story is much more detailed than
that and you you've traveled around the
world looking at
the war on drugs and drugs in general
and stuff like that which is something
the book weaves your personal story with
some of the experiences you've had
elsewhere and the research that you've
done into the into drugs yeah so one of
the one the few good things about
prisons I had a lot of time to read yeah
so I kind of became quite obsessed with
like the whole reason why certain things
are legal and certain things are not so
cuz for me when I was a drug dealer none
of the stuff I saw was like the sort of
stereotypical kind of like pimping out
junkies when they can't pay their 20
quid crack rocks to be fair Niko you
were a drug dealer in bath but yeah so I
would like for me it struck me I saw
myself more as kind of like like a
bartender you know so I it wasn't unfair
that I got worked up cause like they say
don't do the crime if you can't do the
time but it did kind of something did
seem very off so I started reading a lot
about it in jail you get obsessed with
certain subjects very easily as you have
nothing else to do so yeah I kind of go
obsessed with that and afterwards when I
got out my golf probation so I could
leave the country finally I I started
going around the world went to places
like Russia Iran Philippines I just
wanted to find out more about this the
drug problem and yeah the result is this
book I mean so what will you selling
when you were a drug dealer we just we'd
were you selling the hardest stuff oh
sweet coke MDMA so basically everything
you need for a good night out
sounds like you're still working right
now well and so what happened to you
just tell everybody before we get into
some of the research that you've done
and the stuff like that you you were
selling the stuff you you went on the
tube in London with some coke in your
pocket is that right yeah well as MDMA
in America so basically I'd moved to
London I was going to a uni there and I
know that one the tactics that the Met
uses to get a few easy arrest stats is
they stand on top of the escalators with
some sniffer dogs and that's why I
always tell I was aware of this tactic
so I was always telling people didn't
take drugs until there are dogs on a
tube or if I would have to do that I I
put in a glass jar because it takes a
while for smells to get through glass
but that day I was in a rush so I
thought [ __ ] it I just put like a few
reps of MDMA in my back pocket and I set
off and the dumb thing is I actually got
off at the wrong tube station mm-hm
I go off at Tottenham Court Road if I go
off at good Street like I was supposed
to none of this would have happened I
wouldn't be here probably have a real
job like writing up Excel spreadsheets
somewhere yeah but here we are
I was actually when I was arrested so
what I had it's about three grams so
that I could still brag that was a
personal now but they're in half gram
raps so look like six grams so I there's
not really much I could say there and
when they went to my house and my
housemates were still there and they'd
actually ordered a pizza half an hour
before the feds came it's the pizza man
and the police came at the same time
knows a very confused pizza man well
these coppers are taking down like
massive bags of weed like bags of cash
and yeah I got the two and a half years
of which I did just under a year because
I didn't start any fights right all
right and how much money were you making
as a drug dealer all right this is one
thing that annoys me about drug dealers
a lot they're saying like oh yeah I made
like 2 grand this week but like at least
like half of that money is gonna go
towards buying more drugs because you
have to have a sustainable business
model but like in terms of pure profit I
would say I was probably on about like
22 K year give
takes a like yuppie salary 22k a year
likens just profit No okay right okay
like if it's and the money the pass
through my hands probably some more like
fifty hundred yeah something like that
I love how what annoys you about drug
dealers is their poor accounting
practices more than anything else these
guys are selling drugs that are killing
our kids but [ __ ] them they've got [ __ ]
accounting practices that's what really
pisses me off right so you you get
caught you go to jail for officially
two-and-a-half years you come after a
year and in in the time you kind of
started to question well why is the
stuff that you had in your pocket
illegal but tobacco alcohol etc why are
these drugs legal those two in
particular the big ones yeah so for
example like I do sell weed and there is
not a single record of weed killing
anyone ever in the history of mankind
not like directly anyway and then maybe
some fell asleep in the wheel and
crashed but that's not direct but I do
have like one friend in Russia who
killed four people in a drunk driving
accident and that's kind you can
directly pretty much link that to
alcohol so I thought why is this one
league if anything when you're stoned
you're a more careful driver you slow
down I feel like we're promoting all the
wrong things if you want to be a drug
dealer do not take drugs on the tube be
careful when you drive stone-like what
other tips you got no but but the main
thing actually is the impact on on your
own body from consuming drugs yeah right
because tobacco and alcohol are
incredibly toxic and bad for you there
are other drugs that are not and also in
terms of their psychic of not psychic
psychological effects right there are
you know marijuana for example there are
some people there's there's a link to
psychosis but broadly speaking it's a
drug that makes people into nicer people
yeah wears something like alcohol or
cocaine really doesn't right yeah so
you've explored some of that as well so
why is it that these harmful unpleasant
dangerous anti-social drugs are legal
and yet there are other drugs which you
might say are not as bad which are
illegal how do we start how did to start
I think like a lot of it has to do with
it's not so much the effect of the drugs
themselves it's like some social
political or cultural thing that was
going on a certain time which led to
that so for example I was in Iran and
there okay well in Iran pretty much
everything is illegal like you can get
arrested for having the wrong haircut
even but you'd be locked up night
according to our fans anyway yeah
trigonometry fans would get in the run
what you locked up so one thing that's
funny in Iran is so alcohol is it's it's
it'll be legal for us because we're not
we're not Muslim so it's also legal for
all the the Armenian refugees who fed
the Turkish Genocide the descendants of
them so basically yeah if you want some
booze and alcohol call Kim Kardashian
what's funny there is that opium it's
very much they're both illegal but opium
is kind of more tolerated because
there's nothing in the Koran there's
nothing in the Islamic law specifically
about opium and if you really want to
dig deep like according to some
interpretations it's only a very
specific kind of alcohol which should be
they've blanket banned alcohol but in
some interpretations a very specific
kind of our code should be banned so
that's just give you an idea that around
the world different cultures view this
differently
another thing so we'd originally so when
we was banned in America it was 1937 I
think and the American prohibition
lasted from 1919 to 1933 so there was 14
years or smoking joint was legal but
having a drink wasn't and the reason
part of the reason that happened was so
there was like a bunch of these
prohibition narcs
led by a guy called Harry I'm singer
from the federal prohibition Bureau and
once they saw that the Sun was setting
on the booze ban they didn't want to
like sit around with their dicks in
their hands we need to get redundant
they wanted to get in the job so one way
they did that was they start stoking
fear about marijuana so they may they
paid for films like or they supported
films sorry
like reefer madness right movie have you
seen a piano scene oh it's incredible
faster he's one of the funniest films
I've is top 10 funny films it's
brilliantly yeah reefer madness check it
out from the 30s yeah it's yeah yeah
yeah it's very funny as fish cod wander
and but but it's interesting so what
you're essentially saying is that it was
just a way for the police to guarantee
themselves a job yeah pretty much that
and at the time there was a big influx
of Mexicans like refugees from the
Mexican Revolution
so people are quite scared of them so
they are so as easy to kind of if you
kind of attached Mexican immigrants to
cannabis in the media you'd scare away
the white working-class more and they'd
be more likely to support measures
against it which is part of why I'm in
America or here we call it cannabis more
but in America they call it marijuana
because sounds more Mexicans like
marijuana Tijuana ah there you go that's
very very interesting interesting so so
part of it is kind of maintaining the
police force having something to do and
part of it as you say is is about
creating tensions between different
ethnic communities yeah and the United
States actually essentially forced
everyone else to join in the war on
drugs didn't they yeah is the 9.i drugs
of some drugs were so gradually being
banned around the world already and so
for obviously like China had the opium
war
so they took a harsh stance and anything
psychedelic but it was really America
which got the the UN involved and made
everyone signed a binding treaty I think
there are some countries that held out I
think like Nepal didn't sign up to like
the 70s which is why in the polls like
such a great destination for hippies in
the 60s is known for its hash but yeah
it was mostly American boats what's
funny now is that like now America is
kind of backing off
so I even someone like hardline like
Donald Trump they're like saying that
cannabis marijuana legalization psycho
states issue is pretty much staying out
of that like he is a douche bag on other
fronts but I I appreciate that stance
broken clock is Right twice a day but
it's other countries like China Russia
Iran that are fighting the drug war the
hardest I think and so you've been
talking about it essentially jobs for
the boys but can we all just admit that
the drug war has failed it's you know we
talk about a drug war and essentially
yeah I didn't it hasn't won its we
filmed this in London if I want to go
and get cocaine it will take maximum 15
20 minutes I just go with Hugo Chavez's
ashes my [ __ ] body that is a dark
image right there but you know Francis
makes a good point which is drugs are
everywhere yeah hundreds of thousands of
people have been killed around the world
probably more over the time the drug war
has been waged it doesn't seem to be
succeeding why is it still going on I
think just the status quo thing like
it's very difficult for politicians to
get in front of a mic and say like hey
guys remember that time we spent loads
of money we sent a bunch of you to jail
Oh tore apart your families start off
wars in third-world countries for no
good reason
yeah about that I like it's it's
very hard to do a sort of a u-turn on
that you know like any politician to try
said they're gonna be seen as soft and
crying there was a one person I met as
he was a foreign police chief of Brixton
I think his name's Brian paddock so he
basically he ran for Parliament yeah he
was a Lib Dem oh okay wasn't he also as
well he ran for the City of London man
yeah I think he might be yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you met him when he was working
for the police did you say no when when
when he is the Lord already all right
this year yeah madam so he had a policy
in I think 2002 2003 he basically told
his men to like lay off the weed so if
they saw someone smoking like they might
give them a citation take the guns off
them and then that was it and what
happened was it freed up a lot of police
time where they could solve real crimes
so like I think like the burglary or the
street the mugging rate like haft and
also like the arrest for harder drugs
like crack and stuff went way up but
then of course the Daily Mail got wind
of it and yeah he's he was accused of
being soft on drugs and there was like
some kind of smear story in the press
that he was like a dope fiend himself
and he had to abandon the scheme but I
think now people are more open to that
because now I think especially in the UK
like a lot more local police forces are
adopting a similar sort of policy so I
think there's some room for change and
also as well I mean we're always told
about how our country is broke or the
u.s. is broke it's a guaranteed revenue
earner isn't it just for tax you
legalize it you tax it let the dollars
we'll just pounds flow in yeah Iran was
it last year maybe this year that in
Colorado were they Glee guys I think at
the the amount of tax they're having one
year it's hit the 1 billion dollar mark
so imagine that like
when they said about what's it like 250
million for the NHS we could raise that
selling ganja man you look like you're
ready to go there's a big backpack over
there that's ready to roll
there was a very serious question there
so you were talking about former police
chief of Britain and Britain is a
community you know the Caribbean
community who have been targeted because
you know they especially with
Rastafarianism you know they always part
of their religion to smoke weed and all
the rest of it but that is a community
that has been targeted and demonized and
arrested yeah constantly full smoking
weed selling weed all the rest of it
yeah it's so it's something we see
around the world so I can see a word
like the Arabs in France or like in in
Russia with like Central Asians and
gypsies and I think that create an
America obviously with black people and
also Hispanics so I think that creates a
sort of very corrosive cycle because
you're arresting people on mass they go
to jail they're not going to learn
anything good in jail that meanwhile
their families broken up their kids like
running on the streets without a dad
they come out they have like this sort
of brought this sort of jailhouse
mentality with them so if their kid is
and already in a gang they're probably
couldn't get [ __ ] up by this point and
then we wonder like oh why didn't these
communities get their act again because
you keep throwing them in jail
you don't like give them a chance to
kind of evolve whereas for example the
the Asian community in America hasn't
been as targeted and they're flourishing
now the rates of drug use the same in
Asian community in America as they are
father um not sure probably about the
same yeah that's interesting because
that'd be interesting to explore I'm not
sure how true that is because part of it
is cultural as you said right different
people from yeah backgrounds do
different things so in terms of the well
actually let me ask you this since you
you were arrested with MDMA do you think
all drugs should be legalized I don't
think we have to legalize all drugs but
I think
we should legalize at least a Korell of
drugs so for example I think it's
necessary to miss legalize crystal meth
for example I think that would be a good
thing for society why because it's just
insane [ __ ] what so what you're
basically saying is the consequences of
people using that drug are so bad yeah
that it shouldn't be legal which I
suppose is the argument the people who
think marijuana or whatever are bad are
also making right except it's not
factual in my opinion well let me let me
expand on that so basically some meth is
a stimulant at the end of day but if you
legalize like for example if you made
like a legal version of cocaine or MDMA
it's and it's another I'm feta mean like
crystal meth I think you would take away
a lot of the the market for meth anyway
you know I also didn't need to lock up
the user but it also take a big chunk of
the market waste for example right now
we have this problem with spice right
like especially among homeless people
and in prisons I never smoked in prison
I only got the I only got the real
massively overpriced prison weed but
people do smoke it in prison
but showing you cook you just explain
what spices because we've got listeners
and viewers from all around the world
they might not be aware of and also we
have listeners of years who don't take
drugs they are so minority of spice it's
like a kind of fake chemical weed which
originally came about because like
because weed is illegal so the people
tried chemists invented it to kind of
get around the law because we disband
but this isn't yet hmm
so but the problem with that is whereas
we've had like decades of research of
cannabis we know what it does makes you
hungry sleepy your doritos are going to
be gone in the morning
but with spice we don't fully know what
it does and could be and in fact usually
is like a lot more danger the risk of
psychosis is much higher I really know
that much about it
to be honest but from what I saw of it
in gel it looks like nasty [ __ ]
but people wouldn't smoke that if they
had the alternative available if they
could smoke cannabis so people not as
many people I think would take crystal
meth because if they're looking for a
buzz they could take something safer
instead so something they could take
ecstasy they could take okay and they
could take like a week or amphetamine
yeah so what you're saying is the
legalization of certain drugs would take
away the demand for these more harmful
more dangerous drugs Yeah right
so which drugs in your opinion should
remain illegal other than crystal meth
which you've already said well it
depends how you how you define because I
think they should be legalized but in
different ways so for example like
something like weird I think like you
should be able to sell that like the
same you do it's alcohol like you have
the HX getting like special shop or
whatever it's more interesting for
something like heroin so I don't think
heroin should be sold in like Waitrose
next to the frozen fish no just in
little next to the buggies and the
[ __ ] screwdrivers or whatever yeah
[Music]
Harry Sainsbury's tasted different
everything but so but what they've done
in some countries like I think
Switzerland and Netherlands and Germany
is they put it on prescription and you
can only get in special clinics so you
go in get your smack shoot up like in
the presence of a nurse I didn't think
and there's a record or at least I
haven't found a record of anyone ever
OD'ing at these places could so under
medical supervision it's so pure stay on
there know what those they're getting
and it's free so they don't have to go
around boosting TVs like Trainspotting
so that that's how like heroin would be
legalized in my opinion and in fact I
think we actually had that system in
Britain until
80s when Reagan got involved and told
Thatcher to cut this [ __ ] out and I
think since the 80 is like the number of
smack addicts has grown actually
exponentially because they also have a
motive to introduce get other people
hooked as well it's like a pyramid
scheme so they're saying to support
their habit to get other people's hooked
and so on mmm that's very very
interesting so you're saying that heroin
it should be licensed but essentially
for people who are addicted to heroin
yeah
what about cocaine because with cocaine
it's very interesting you have cocaine
obviously the powder but then you have
crack yeah there are two completely
different types of drugs would you
legalize both for just legalized
actually the same drug they're the same
drug that consumed differently but
fundamentally it's the same drug but
they hate that you get from crack well
[Laughter]
that's uh that's a good question I'm not
I'm not fully sure about cooked came
because like I think it's one of the
most like like next alcohol actually
it's one of the most dangerous toxic
things you could put in your body is it
really like more so than heroin like if
you took pure heroin like you got those
critics every day for twenty years you
might give it constipated but like you
wouldn't really suffer any long-term
damage whereas if you were drinking
every day or if you're snorting a lion
every day you'd have some serious heart
problems liver problems so yeah it's a
cokes an interesting work because it
does make people some people act like
dicks it's filed under I don't I don't
have the answer that one but I'm sure
there's like some some middle ground I
think that definitely coca tea which
they have in South America which is
legal in a lot of South America which is
basically like a cup of coffee I think
that's I think there shouldn't be any
restrictions are at all I mean in theory
you could go to like as the by like
thirty kilos of coca leaves and make
like one gram of coke but I think you
know if you are that determined fair
play to you
but it's also as well because I mean
London has a huge cocaine problem like I
saw it's like in the top maybe it's the
top city in Europe for cocaine
consumption I remember that there was a
headline last week yeah that wouldn't
make complete sense
yeah do you not think it would it would
it would it's just better if we just go
look you can buy it you know what the
government will regulate it they'll -
instead of what happens now which is
quite literally you go to a toilet and a
pub and you have to wait ten minutes
because someone's snorting coke in there
just take the toilets out of the cocaine
room man Nika I wanted to ask you about
kind of crime and prison and the kind of
the drug-dealing mind say if you like
like when how did you get into selling
drugs well I'm not gonna lie I am
disgustingly middle-class so I guess I
was also kind of very insecure I was
quite a weak person I guess so I kind of
I always and I got picked on a lot for
being like always being the new kid for
being the foreign kid so I kind of
wanted to prove myself but I was too
much of like a little [ __ ] to be like a
real gangster it's just like robbed
people and stuff so I thought like if I
did like drugs I'd have like some more
respect I'd have more friends I'd have
more money it just seemed like an easy
way out if you keep bullying Russians
I'm gonna start dealing drugs and this
podcast will become profitable yeah but
how did you what I mean is like okay
that's that was your situation as a kid
how do you go from that to suddenly
you're selling drugs to people because
you have to go and buy them from
somebody yeah you have to like be like
okay I'm a drug dealer now do you know
what I mean I kind of got in like my
sort of my door my door I got my foot
through the door through illegal rave
parties so there's a lot of that going
on and also legal legal rave parties lot
going on in Bristol I'm not gonna name
the clubs or a place involved but it's
they're not hard to find
I'm so breast has like a huge drum and
bass scene
also perhaps coincidentally huge Katamon
seen like a huge size on scene so I just
kept going to those eventually I got
introduced to people and that is from
there it's quite easy so I meet people
then you meet more people and it's like
a mushrooming network you know so I
started out very much setting XC at
raves so I was like I was the dodgy guys
in the corner going weed pills weed
pills right and yeah of entry that moved
on to coke and is it I mean I I don't
mean this to sound judgmental I'm just
trying to understand is there any point
a part of you that goes what I'm doing
is wrong not really like the time when I
did see afterwards like I did see like
the misery of addiction on what drugs
can do to people that was only
afterwards and I was proactively looking
for that stuff in my book like it's not
all sunshine and roses like I had to
I actually met met a guy called ray
forgot his surname is her name surname
evades me but he's a he's a former
teacher from the Isle of Wight no the
Isle of Man sorry and he lost both his
sons to ecstasy in one night which was
pretty [ __ ] up like they went to a
football game and they didn't come back
and it turns out that they their waiter
found on the second floor of a pub and
they'd taken like six times the lethal
dose of ecstasy Jesus and that was like
a very shocking story really stuck with
me because tells you shows you what this
stuff can do and but when I was meeting
ray it's like I had this sort of like
really tight feeling in my stomach cuz I
thought he'd be the kind of guy you know
who'd hate my guts but really has the
same standpoint as me so like if they
cuz when you're buying drugs even from
from someone like me you don't really
know what you're getting there isn't
like a warning label saying you know a
contain nuts like that's the biggest
problem yeah so like if they knew what
they were getting if they knew at the
exact dose and what the the help like
the healthy dose for other people was
and if they go from a shop or whatever
like a licensed shop they could check
the ingredients they'd still be alive
today yeah so his standpoint was
essentially the same as mine
and well where do you stand on you know
because you were talking about you know
you started dealing in illegal raves at
lyrical rapes I'm sure that you probably
did it like you said at certain
nightclubs where do you stand with the
whole the police do which is a shot and
nightclub down if drug dealers are found
to be operating there as to happen to
fabric earlier this year although just
go somewhere else
people just go where the party is like
so why go shut down all the clubs in
London okay the people are just gonna
throw warehouse parties or parties in
the fields like they did back in the 90s
like it's um it's called the balloon
effect so you crack down on drugs in one
place it just pops up somewhere else so
I see Pablo Escobar got killed in what
92-93 a great man cartels came tumbling
the short time after the Cali cartel
went down then what happened like the
drug business just moved to Mexico
Mexico is now the the most important
nation for drug trafficking in the
Western Hemisphere so and and but why do
you think we we need to take drugs
because surely you know this court
that's quite a loaded question I'm not
sure we necessarily need to take drugs
the question pod casting they do need to
take drugs how many people take drugs on
this planet and it's more than the PETA
doesn't mean they need to it might mean
that they are genetically predisposed to
or they might feel like taking them
doesn't mean they need to you need to
breathe oxygen you don't necessarily
need to take drugs the message of
trigonometry you know that you need to
take drugs and what I'm trying to say
I'm trying to pre empty all the [ __ ]
libel suits or whatever the
come out to the shows ice actually
especially in the last years has been
quite a lot of research that in some
ways some drugs in some ways can be good
for you like right now there's our
research in America about using MDMA for
treating PTSD so they're trying it now
on War veterans people coming back from
Iraq Afghanistan I think the the
organization is called Maps I forgot
what it stands for but it's called maps
you guys can look it up and I think they
had like an 81 percent success rate for
treating PTSD so that's quite good and
um another thing another Avenue it's
being sport now is psychedelics and how
they can kind of change your way of
thinking and thinking around the box so
when I came out of prison because like I
said earlier it's very easy to fixate on
certain things in prison so I became
fixated this one girl that I knew and I
basically became a stalker for a bit and
flash-forward like two years later I'm
in the Amazon about two hours away from
any anything that could be described as
civilization I'm in like a hut with a
shaman and he gives me this they call it
a tea but it just tastes like ass it's
so it's called ayahuasca it's like it
contains DMT which is like the most
solid powerful psychedelic in the
history of man so I drank that a lot of
[ __ ] happen they won't go into all of it
but I went to Kermit land Kermit the
Frog took me on like this Odyssey down
the river it makes you throw up a lot
and I turned to throw up and into a
bucket the bucket was actually there
that wasn't me tripping but who was
holding the bucket but Rafiki from The
Lion King and he was looking like you'll
come with her freaky he know the way and
I just vomited and then I saw there like
a million Jaguar face in the bucket
going in a spiral they didn't look happy
at what I've just done but it also made
me like reassess my life from water
interview and help me get over like a
lot of my kind of not sure if that's the
word that like might draw more my
fixations from prison it's not an issue
for me anymore
because it helped me see outside the box
that I kind of put myself in mice mental
cell as it were well I guess the
question you were really asking before I
really interrupted you just to make a
joke was why is it that people are drawn
to taking drugs
what like there is Johann Hari who talks
about the fact no it's a way of dealing
with trauma what happened what do you
think drives people to take certain
drugs do you mean like drives people to
just use drugs or drives and
specifically to like addiction and bad
stuff I guess both well I take them one
at a time we're just drugs it's the same
same reason for us drinking a cup of
coffee or like have smoking a cigarette
talking with your friends going for a
walk playing sports or whatever it's
just uh it's just something to do it's
just the way to be sociable to be happy
having a drink it's the same thing what
happens with addiction is so obviously
like thousands of people snort lines
across the whole of London every
Saturday night right but only like a
small portion of them go on to do it
like impulsively where they're it's like
5:00 a.m. on a Monday and they're still
doing coke so like I think with a lot of
those people like one a friend of mine
she can be described as let's say a
problem
coke user and she got raped a lot when
she was a kid she was like six to nine
years old I think she was repeatedly
raped by a family friend so I think like
for a lot of people I get addicted and
the same with hard drinking they're kind
of trying to numb the pain in their
lives trying to get over something some
hang up they have some trauma they have
and I think that's eventually that's
where kind of the chemical hooks
graduate
set in and that's when you start having
a problem and do you think that when you
look let's say like let's take a drug
like cocaine alright so you have to go
to a drug dealer to get it you buy the
drugs you then if I have to find a place
where nobody's seeing you in order to
take the drug and then you know the
entire process make it gives us sort of
glamour to it doesn't it
a sort of dark dirty glamour that if you
went and you just bought it in a shop
somewhere a licensed shop it just
wouldn't have yeah it feels a bit
naughty yeah and you think that's part
of it that you know people feel it's
naughty therefore they want to do it
more I think you know that could there
could be something to that because if
you look at if you look at the
Netherlands you know look at amst a mall
there coffee shops know the bulldog
Dutch people they actually smoke that
much weed like compared to us I'd say
most of the people smoking weed in
Amsterdam are Brits and the stag do and
French teenagers so yeah there's
something in that sort of forbidden
fruit appeal there's also kind of I
think here in Britain we have like
highest rates of like binge drinking on
the continent or at least in Western
Europe like Russia's a whole other - but
like somewhere like in France then
really have that problem because people
just drink have a glass of wine with
their parents when they're like 13 14
and like they're kind of eased into it
they know not to overdo it from an early
age so I think yeah I think there's
something in that definitely and what
about I just want to come back to this
start of your kind of drug-dealing
career cuz it doesn't occur to you that
any of this is wrong you're selling
these drugs do you have like you
obviously have to avoid the police you
have to think about that stuff even at
that point it doesn't it doesn't cross
your mind then again I don't mean this
in the way I'm just trying to get into
the mindset it doesn't cross your mind
that what you're doing is wrong yeah
like it obviously I know it's illegal
but I don't see it as as wrong as like a
bad thing I was like an immoral thing
because for me there's a big difference
between
what's moral and what's legal yeah so
for example like the people hit and
Frank during world war two they're
acting illegally under the German
occupation but I wouldn't say they were
acting morally obviously I'm not
comparing myself like I'd say like a rum
runner during the Prohibition during the
American prohibitions on who smuggled
whiskey in from Canada like it's illegal
the government says it's wrong but you
know everyone drinks all your friends
drink like it doesn't really occur to
you that it that it's like an immoral
bad evil thing all right and then you
get arrested yeah and what happens
mentally at that point for you that was
that was a big shock to the system
because no one ever thinks they're
getting caught otherwise they wouldn't
do it that's why I think like things
like the death penalty doesn't work
because no one's thinks they get caught
in the first place
there's a lot of evidence for that
actually that it's not the extent of the
punishment but the certainty of being
correctly heard yeah yeah that has a
much bigger effect on offending so
people think that they're gonna get a
slap on the wrist but it's a hundred
percent yeah much less likely to do
things
yeah then if they're gonna get a really
bad punishment but it's like ten percent
chance of it happening yeah yeah so you
didn't think you were gonna get caught
like most people know and then BAM you
get caught yeah
also for a while I feel like by being
like a sort of white middle class
student I'd be in a few situations with
the police before where I did either get
just a slap on the wrist or they didn't
even suspect me to begin with so that
kind of made me more kind of arrogant I
guess or careless I know what the right
word here would be but when I actually
did get caught it's just like there's a
one side metal door slams shut yo you
think like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what do I do
now what do i do what do I do what I do
and for a while like I was pretty not
calm but like my mind didn't really
accept it
except that this was real until I
actually got sent down
for two and a half years and then then I
went a bit insane because I was like
okay I'm here now
no one's gonna rescue me Batman's not
gonna come busting in through the window
and then I immediately start thinking of
things to do and I calculated my
sentence down to the second and I
started like counting down like 1
million nine hundred thousand and 99 and
so on and then I eventually I gave up
after about an hour and I realized this
actually wasn't making time go far it
was making a lot a lot slower right
mm-hmm
and do you think from your experience
which prison were you in a house in to
prisons first I was in a HMP tam site
which is all right you know better than
a Travel Lodge yeah and then the other
one is it's the Hilton and the other one
was right next door as the appropriately
named HMP Isis which was just a [ __ ] box
we called it crisis right okay now so
you had you had you spent a significant
amount of time in prison does it work as
a way to rehabilitate offenders from
what you saw mm nah I think maybe with
sort of like medium term offenders maybe
I try to no because while I was there
I'd sometimes see people get released
and I'd see them come back out come back
in come back in come back in sorry yeah
and it was just over just the stupidest
[ __ ] I mean not like some people do take
the the opportunity to change their
lives around but you really have to be
kind of determined to do that because
when you're in jail everything's
actually against you're surrounded by
your fellow co-conspirators we make new
links especially in Isis which is in
offenders institution there's a lot of
street gangs like postcode wars and
stuff so it's very easy to get drawn
into that
yeah I think apart from like vile like
violent offenders and kiddy Fiddler's I
don't think people should really be sent
to prison as much as they are now it
seems to work for you though
well I got a bunch of new material yeah
no but my point is you're doing
something very different now to what you
were doing before right that is true and
it sounds like prison was for you a wake
up call
does that fair to say hmm sounds like
you know what to tell us what it was
like I think it's more in my case it's
because I had a strong family so my
family still supported me but I think if
I didn't think if what my mama thought
of all this wasn't constantly on my mind
as well I think that I could have very
easily gone back and being a bigger drug
dealer I've got links to like rush shows
Beck is done Brazil Bulgaria now all
over the place like if I didn't have and
a lot of the people in um in prison they
come from either one parent households
or sometimes no parent households so I
think for them it's a lot more difficult
hmm and what would taste worse steps
taken to try and rehabilitate you to try
and give you other skills that you could
perhaps use on the outside will you just
sort of left to it well for me I was
already doing my masters by that point
so like that's sort of well [ __ ] i.t
class that I did on the side didn't
really help much I just used that for
our writing and printing off letters
because I was too lazy to write them in
myself hmm
but one thing that's interesting the
painting and decorating course is very
popular so I bet I'm gonna say that's in
like nine out of ten paints and
decorators in this country are probably
ex-cons really really Wow I'm now having
my house redecorated again I'm just
messing but what so you talked about how
when you are in prison you have a lot of
time to think about stuff is the
environment that you're in a big factor
in why we see that the mental health
epidemic
is so so so prevalent and so terrible in
jails yeah absolutely I mean especially
now like in the last few years because
of all the cutbacks so I even when I was
in I think 2016 that's when they really
started kicking up but even when I was
in prison like the officers rewarding
like there's gonna be riots when they
start buying tobacco they start doing
cut back so our prison Isis they
basically cut half the stuff Wow
so that means that they couldn't run
half the prison effectively at any given
time so half the prison was shut down so
we could be in our cell for up to 23 and
a half hours a day they like they let us
out for like compulsory exercise and
that's it and what will affect it is
that like mentally be in the room for
twenty three and a half hours well I'll
tell you Jeremy Carl gets boring real
quick so you do have a TV and stuff but
it yeah yeah you have a TV if you behave
yourself you get a TV I think the TV is
a good thing because it wasn't there
we'd have a lot more rights that's how
Strangeways happened pretty much because
people were just like you see people
newspapers say yeah I stuff enough our
prison it's just a holiday camp I think
those people been taking the wrong
holidays and I also think that's how
that's how riots happened like we need
tough enough prisons you don't make
people learn their lesson you make
people more mentally deranged you get
this sort of weird thinking about time
that you don't have on the outside
you're always counting down so you're
always thinking like okay now it's 12
o'clock I'm gonna have lunch in an hour
or whatever
six o'clock Simpsons gonna be on channel
4 10 o'clock and get a good bed five
more days of this then it's the weekend
they get more visit two more weeks till
the end of the month three more months
till the end of the year one more year
so I'm released like and think about
that in the real world you think of time
that way and that can really really [ __ ]
with your mind and one of one other
thing I want to charge you about
obviously a lot of our impressions about
prison I actually taken from American
movies yeah so it's the Shawshank
Redemption there what's the one with the
green moil
the Green Mile boy what's the one with a
Norton so American History X right so
it's all about violence sexual violence
yes that's right what is the situation
like for someone like you who as you say
as a white middle-class kid going in on
a relatively short stint compared to
maybe some of the other people in the
prison in terms of you know being
assaulted being beaten up and stuff like
that actually then I was fine um I used
to work out a lot more back then so I
was a lot bigger I don't I tried to be
like respect for anyone I was involved
any of the gang stuff so I was fine
pretty much but I did see like a lot of
stuff go down so one guy get hit in the
eye with like a tunic on in the sock and
he was walking around looking like
two-faced from Batman for about a week a
lot of I think we've told people enough
illegal [ __ ] for the podcast there's a
lot of stabbings with let's say sharpen
toothbrushes like toothbrushes with
little razor blades attached melted into
listen yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna tell
you guys how to do that no but but the
reason I asked about it what I mean is
is there a lot of that going on yeah and
why is it going on you mentioned like
the gang stuff so if you as a person you
you're in prison you're not part of a
gang are you generally gonna be alright
as long as you don't if you're not being
a dick to people or whatever I think
yeah especially in like the the big man
jail so I was Isis is a young offender
so 18 to 25
there was one 28 year old there by
mistake he wasn't happy but again an
adult prison I think most people just
want to kind of do their time and get on
with it really young offenders it's
different you have a lot more bullying
or more intimidation just because that's
just full of young want to be gangsters
want to prove themselves but yeah
generally it's not as bad as
they say but it still it can be pretty
bad it can so your way of do of getting
through it was essentially keeping your
head down did you make any sort of
connections there did you did you meet
people or is it something that you just
literally went I'm not going to talk to
anyone it's gonna be I'm just going to
have tunnel vision every day I'm just
gonna keep my interaction so that's
impossible you'll go crazy from that now
Ike I try to make friend there's always
like a couple of cool people in each
wing I remember there was one group
that's everyone called the Russians
which was basically consists of me the
only actual Russian about six Lithuanian
guys that would get really pissed off he
called them polish and then one was Beck
guy everyone just called us Russia
because they didn't bother with
geography but someone shouted Russia
cross the wing about eight people would
turn around yeah they were cool just
played cards all day really yeah
oh um met the guy who stopped professor
green he was an interesting character he
was a bad guy he stole I think three
million pounds sending viruses to banks
and then siphon off the money but he
[ __ ] up went on one day he forgot to
turn the encryption on his laptop so he
traced those his IP address and yeah he
got done for like fraud money laundering
all kinds of [ __ ] so that's really
interesting so think it's almost you
know all this survival isn't it you go
in there and then you kind of meet
like-minded people yeah you have to you
have to and that's the way you get
through it but you don't think it works
with the vast majority of people like
really it should be about rehabilitation
it should be about bringing someone in
trying to do your best to fix and give
them skills so they can survive in the
outside world that's what they do in
Norway actually Norway has a like a
really good prison system they I think
they even have internet there I think
Anders Breivik isn't allowed Internet
he can't like go Instagram his faux
Nazis but most prisons there are didn't
like some it's like school librarians no
it's like obviously a bunch of stuff is
filtered but yeah you can still talk to
your family the sentence their sentences
are what shorter I think on some prisons
like we can just walk around you don't
have to be like bang up six o'clock in
yourself for the rest of the night and I
think they're there reoffending Reynaud
it's something like fifteen percent
whereas with us I think it's something
closer to half Wow so what every person
every other person who comes out of
prison is gonna go back in yeah I don't
quote me on the exact statistic but it
is much higher than no more or less
maybe a third or 40% something like that
and you must have encountered paperwork
you just looked him and they just
thought look we need to rehabilitation
at chance but you must have met the odd
person who's like there's no [ __ ] way
you should be outside oh man there are
these two guys were there's um those two
French like cartoon characters Gotham's
big and the other ones small and like
they fight the Romans as Horatio
knoblauch's
yeah they're so these two guys looked
exactly like Asterix and Obelix and the
big fat one he was a [ __ ] psycho man
like I was cool with him but like some
people don't need to be in jail and some
people need to be in jail and he
definitely needs to be in jail why was
Ari astra let's hope he never comes out
and finds out and starts watching
trigonometry thanks for coming in Nico I
recommend everybody get this book and
read it it's it's a great read and it's
like I said it weaves his personal story
when with a lot of facts and research
into the drug war in truth it's a really
good read
thanks for sending us a copy and as
always follow your on Twitter but you
know very active on there right oh I you
might win a game as week yeah there's a
dog follow him on Twitter but follow us
and we'll see you again in a week from
now with another brilliant episode take
care see you next week guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pot and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word